you guys watch us and tell me which
school's the best all right
what do shorter days blaring alarm
clocks and packed lunches all have in
common
yep just like that students everywhere
are hitting the books and attending
classes
whether you're getting ready to march
down the halls or logging into an online
classroom
we all know there's nothing quite like
disney school supplies doesn't matter if
it's nostalgic and retro
or current and contemporary today we're
highlighting all of our favorite back to
school disney merch
featuring everything from nostalgic
classics to today's latest hits that you
wish you had as a kid
oh great for now um how about boots
winter boots elsa and anna are easily
the most recognizable disney characters
from a mile away
and with good reason we all know that
they're each stunning queens in their
own right which is bound to elevate your
tote bag game
great alternative to backpacks this toad
could easily go from school to weekend
in no time
if we had this bag you know we'd never
take it off i've got a person
in my closet speaking of elevating your
everyday back to school disney
essentials this tangled water bottle
featuring the one and only rapunzel is
sure to turn some heads
your body and hair will thank you for
all the water you drink with this
customizable
yep you heard it right bottle where was
this when we were in school
yes now back up while i deal with this
crook here
now if you're getting ready to wander
down the halls you'll definitely need
one of these
it's undeniable that face masks are the
accessory of the year so why not pay
tribute to your favorite disney
franchise while at it with motives from
star wars to marvel
to disney princesses and monsters inc
you'll actually feel good about putting
one of these on
and the fact that they come in four
packs is really helpful for those of us
who seem to misplace things everywhere
i like to stare at a wishing well i
start the ocean horse trough
soap bubbles if you were the creative
artistic kid in your classroom then you
would have absolutely wanted to get your
hands on these a deluxe art set with
crayons
markers paints oh my this disney tin
case
art kit comes in a mickey mouse or our
personal favorite princess emoji motif
with all the supplies your heart desires
plus its convenient carrying case with
the handle is easy to tag along
everywhere
after all you never know when creativity
will strike i never thought i'd get to
wear a reel
what's it called again oh yeah shirt
speaking of disney princesses this next
accessory is sure to have been the envy
of all your friends
this analog clock featuring ariel on the
clock face has a timeless and nostalgic
feel to it plus
it would have been a serious help when
we were trying to learn how to retime
with the appropriately labeled hands
marked hour and minutes you can bet that
part of your world would have changed if
you were wearing one of these back in
the day
oh yeah i found out that fairy godmother
has been with the wanda coronation we
all got to go
who says school stationery has to be
boring and uninspiring if this notebook
was around when we were in school
then we wouldn't have hesitated to hit
the books this descendants journal nods
to mao's spell book and although a
subtle touch to your back-to-school
shopping list true fans of the series
will want to get their hands on your
notes
or maybe even your spells i'll just wait
for mom to get back what
well she won't understand it any better
than i do the incredibles franchise is
arguably the most loved among older and
younger audiences
everywhere the 14-year gap between the
first and second disney pixar flick
has both generations in love with the
wickedly talented family so if you were
to rock this shirt to school your
friends and teachers alike will
appreciate the ode to the modern day
superhero classic
not to mention if the rumors of a third
installment are true and take just as
long then you can bet this piece will
age well in anybody's closet i didn't do
anything
could you stop not doing anything
speaking of disney classics that
transcends generations peter pan and his
feisty sidekick tinkerbell ought to be
fan favorites
plus is it just us or do you also think
that tinkerbell has the greatest sense
of style
true believers of neverland young and
old will only admire these stylish
shields with the infamous white pompoms
but also start believing in fairies
all over again we have a special place
where you can put your backpack
you want to see we all wanted to bring
our toys with us to school
but between our books field trip forms
and packed lunches
there was never a place to put them in
our backpacks no need to worry about any
of that with this mickey mouse
plush backpack not only will your very
own mickey mouse toy be able to come to
school with you
but he'll also have the best seat in the
house it's undeniable that mickey mouse
is the ultimate disney character
so why not carry him on your back
wherever you go oh i don't know why but
i've
always loved the idea of summer while
some people are strictly team elsa or
team anna there's one thing all frozen
fans can agree on
we're all team olaf with this tumblr
featuring a frozen snow globe we would
have been able to take pieces of erin
doll
including our favorite snowman
everywhere and anywhere
maybe frozen didn't come out when you
were a kid but we know if this had
existed back in the day
it would have been a lunchbox staple no
questions asked
my name is pocahontas
speaking of lunch boxes why not gear
yourself with one that pays tribute to
moana
pocahontas tinkerbell and sleeping
beauty this lunch box's pasta motif with
golden piping and beautiful
illustrations
elevates the lunch boxes we all owned as
a kid although it's labeled as a
lunchbox we could see this bag easily
going from classroom to the weekend in
an instant
if you had this as a kid you'd probably
have to fend off your very own mom from
this beautifully crafted bag
i learned everything i know from my
school monsters university
this cap has a worn in and vintage vibe
that truly looks like any varsity logo
but real monster university fans will
recognize this cap from across the
classroom
a nod to our favorite disney college
this cap is one of those pieces that
both the younger and older generations
can both appreciate
plus if you hang on to it all the way to
college it's bound to blend right into
all that varsity merch
i want to tell you about christmas town
speaking of the older disney generation
nostalgic fans will love this next back
to school accessory
whether you're a little bit more rock
and roll or just feeling a little spooky
this jack skellington nightmare before
christmas backpack is sure to get some
heads turning we love this accessory
because it would instantly start a
conversation about the spookiest disney
movie there is to date
every day is halloween in this backpack
but we've always said this job isn't
about getting played with
if you were that kid who insisted on
playing dress-up every day to school
then one of these costume hoodies will
do the trick
we love these sweaters because it's
equal parts practical and fun
sure it looks like an average hoodie at
first glance but once that hood comes up
you're immediately transformed into your
favorite disney character
we love the woody and stitch hoodies but
there's also plenty of marvel superhero
ones that ought to catch your eye
i've loved you since the first time you
picked up your ukulele
and you wrote a song about clouds
whether you're a big fan of the original
movies
or die hard fan of the new disney plus
series you can show off your love for
your favorite disney high school in this
merch
don't worry singing dancing and playing
basketball are not required to wear any
of this gear
we love this line of gear because it
really does look like normal gear you'd
find at any high school
so if you're looking for a way to show
your love for hsm without singing and
dancing we're all in this together in
the halls
then you're bound to find something in
this disney collection i can get you
more credits
i can bring you in warm with disney
picking up huge franchises like marvel
and star wars
this mandalorian baseball cap is up for
grabs at your local disney store
let's be real whether or not you've seen
the original star wars films or caught a
few mandalorian episodes on disney plus
you can't deny the forces to be reckoned
arguably
of all the disney franchises star wars
lovers are some of the most die-hard
fans
out there so if you're caught in this
hat you're bound to get compliments just
from starting around the courtyard
fans young and old will give you huge
props not only for your fashion sense
but also taste in pop culture tv shows
and films
who made your gown i've never seen
anything quite like it
disney is a world-renowned name and we
can pretty much guarantee it's not going
anywhere
so stocking up on any of these
accessories is a win-win so what's your
favorite back-to-school disney merch
did we miss anything and let us know in
the comments section how you're
motivating yourselves to hit the books
again